T
FAMOUS ALUM WHO SHE QUOTED
THERE.
ALL RIGHT.
>>> STARTING NEXT WEEK BILLIONS
IF NOT TRILLIONS OF TINY
INVADERS WILL BEGIN THEIR
ASSAULT ON NEARLY ALL OF THE
COUNTRY EAST OF THE MISSISSIPPI
RIVER.
THEY HAVE BEEN LAYING IN WAIT
FOR 17 YEARS UNTIL THE TIME AND
TEMPERATURE IS RIGHT TO BEGIN
THEIR DEAFENING DESCENT UPON
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
METEOROLOGIST AND CBS NEWS
CLIMATE SPECIALIST JEFF
BERARDELLI IS HERE WITH THE
STORY.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT BROOD 10
CICADAS.
THINK ABOUT WHERE YOU WERE AND
WHAT YOU WERE DOING BACK IN 2004
BECAUSE THESE INSECTS HAVE BEEN
UNDERGROUND THAT WHOLE TIME.
WHILE PLENTY HAS CHANGED IN OUR
SOCIETY, THESE CICADAS ARE
UNDERGOING A TRANSFORMATION
BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
FILMS ABOUT INVADING INSECTS
HAVE BEEN SCARING MOVIE GOERS
FOR DECADES.
BUT NOW A REAL-LIFE INSECT
INVASION OF WHAT ARE CALLED
PERIODICAL CICADAS WILL PUT
HOLLYWOOD TO SHAME BY ITS SHEER
SIZE AND SCOPE.
THERE ARE OVER A DOZEN KNOWN
BROODS OF CICADAS IN THE U.S.
THIS ONE, BROOD 10, IS
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE LARGEST
AND MAKES ITS APPEARANCE LIKE
CLOCKWORK EVERY 17 YEARS.
>> I THINK IT'S A PRETTY BIG
EVENT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TRILLIONS OF
CICADAS THAT WILL BE EMERGING,
SINGING, CALLING, FINDING MATES
IN YOUR BACKYARD.
>> DR. JESSICA WARE IS BUGGING
OUT WITH EXCITEMENT.
>> THESE ARE THE BROOD 10.
>> SHE'S AN ENTOMOLOGIST AT THE
AMERICAN MUSEUM OF NATURAL
HISTORY IN NEW YORK.
SHE SAYS OVER THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
ALONG THE EAST COAST AND
MIDWEST, THE CICADAS WILL EMERGE
FROM THE GROUND, SHED THEIR
SKINS AND PARTAKE IN A
MONTH-LONG MATING RITUAL, MAKING
QUITE THE SCENE.
CLIMBING TREES AND SINGING
MATING SONGS AS LOUD AS 100
DECIBALS.
THAT'S THE SAME INTENSITY AS A
JACKHAMMER.
>> HOW DO THEY KNOW AFTER 17
YEARS WHEN EXACTLY THEY SHOULD
EMERGE?
>> IT'S NOT THAT THE CICADAS
KNOW ANYTHING PER SE.
I THINK PART OF IT IS HARD
WIRED.
SO THERE'S A SERIES OF
BIOCHEMICAL CASCADES, HORMONES
THAT RISE AND FALL AND SET UP A
TRIGGER.
IF YOU HAVE A CERTAIN HORMONE
LEVEL AND THE TEMPERATURE OF THE
SOIL IS 64 DEGREES, IT'S GO
TIME.
>> ONCE THE CICADAS DO EMERGE,
TIME IS NOT ON THEIR SIDE.
>> THEY'RE ON A SHORT CLOCK.
SO THEY HAVE GOT THREE OR FOUR
WEEKS TO GET THE JOBS DONE.
THEY NEED TO FIND A MATE, THEY
NEED TO DO THE ACTUAL MATING,
FEMALES NEED TO LAY THE EGGS AND
THEN DEATH OCCURS.
>> IF YOU'RE A CICADA, THIS IS
AN EXCITING TIME.
>> IF YOU SPEND 17 YEARS
UNDERGROUND AND YOU'VE GOT THREE
OR FOUR WEEKS TO DO ALL THE
JOBS.
>> WHAT'S EXCITING IS -- IT MAY
BE FRIGHTENING FOR SOME OF US
HUMANS BUT WARE SAYS THEY DON'T
BITE OR STING.
>> THEY POSE NO HARM TO HUMANS
AND REALLY DON'T POSE THAT MUCH
HARM TO THEIR GARDEN.
THEIR GOAL REALLY IS TO FIND
EACH OTHER, TO MATE AND MAKE THE
NEXT GENERATION OF CICADAS.
>> EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T POSE A
THREAT TO US, HUMANS DO POSE A
THREAT TO THEM.
URBAN SPRAWL AND DEVELOPMENT
HAVE DESTROYED ENTIRE
POPULATIONS.
THEY ARE EMERGING ANYWHERE FROM
A WEEK TO A MONTH EARLIER THAN
THEY DID DECADES AGO.
WARE SAYS IT MAY SHORTEN THE
AMOUNT OF YEARS THEY STAY
UNDERGROUND.
ON A MORE POSITIVE NOTE, THESE
WILL BECOME A FEAST FOR MANY OF
NATURE'S OTHER CREATURES, EVEN
SOME BRAVE HUMANS.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOU EAT CICADAS?
>> THEY'RE A GREAT PROTEIN
SOURCE.
I'M EXCITED TO EAT SOME CICADAS.
THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL BOUNTY, A
CORNUCOPIA.
>> WITH DIPPING SAUCES OR
WITHOUT DIPPING SAUCES.
>> I'M A SOPHISTICATED LADY SO I
WOULD GO WITH A ROSEMARY GARLIC
AIOLI.
>> THE MUSEUM IS HAVING A BIG
CICADA SAUTE.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS
PROBABLY ARE TOO BUSY.
THEY'RE DOING IT IN A WEEK OR
SO.
SO I BROUGHT A FEAST FOR YOU
GUYS.
>> NO!
>> YES, I DID.
BRIAN BRING IT ON IN.
>> NO SHOT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I'M NOT HAVING ANY.
>> $10 TO THE FIRST PERSON WHO
EATS CICADAS.
>> NOT HAPPENING.
>> OH!
>> WELL PLAYED.
>> ONE MOVIE YOU DIDN'T MENTION,
ANYBODY WHO'S WITH ME AGEWISE,
1986, LUCAS, WITH ALL OF THE